to remove the subject from the
motorcycle
at that point a physical confrontation
ensued
during the physical confrontation the
male subject
went to retrieve a firearm that he had
held inside a vest
shirt that he was wearing the officer
immediately saw the firearm
feared for his safety and disengaged
creating space
at that point the subject backed up and
retreated into his apartment that was
directly behind him
officers recognizing immediately this
was a barricade
surrounded the location
swat was called to the scene and the
motel was surrounded and evacuations
had started during the process of trying
to conduct evacuations
officers approached the neighboring
apartment and a shot rang out towards
officers
from inside the neighboring apartment
unknown to officers while they were
outside
the male hispanic subject had used a
hammer and a saw that he had inside his
apartment
to create a opening a hole between his
apartment
and the neighboring apartment he was
able to fit through that hole that he
created in the wall
go into the neighboring apartment and
unfortunately
took the female babysitter and
four-year-old little boy
hostage once the officers were able to
during their investigation realize that
we had a hostage situation
swat immediately began to set up to
figure out the quickest and safest way
to get the child and babysitter out of
the apartment
las vegas metropolitan police department
swat team and negotiators on scene
immediately began negotiations with the
subject
via a cell phone
the subject stated clearly throughout
the course of the time
that he was holding them hostage and
they were not free to leave
using an extreme amount of patience and
de-escalation techniques
we very very patiently step by step
negotiated
with the subject about two and a half
hours into these negotiations we were
able to get the
subject to release the little boy into
the care of police
the subject continued to say he did not
want to peacefully surrender
and that he was holding the female
babysitter hostage
we knew he had a firearm and we knew
that he was
willing to fire rounds based on the fact
that he had fired them at us previously
we took this very slowly and
methodically negotiating with him
throughout the entire night
about two and a half hours ago we were
able to get the subject
to release the female babysitter
at this point it became a barricade
we continue to negotiate with him using
the most peaceful methods
possible to get to him to surrender
after 29 hours
the lvnpd negotiations team and swat
team
was able to get him to peacefully with
his hands up walk out of the apartment
and was taken safely into custody
it should be noted that extreme care
and patience and de-escalation was used
throughout this entire incident
this is the kind of thing that the lvmpd
swat team and negotiators train for
and prepare for and there's nothing more
important to us than the sanctity of
life
and that those hostages and that the
subject was taken into custody
without any injury
in a situation like this the subject
dictates
the actions of an incident they are the
ones that set the tone in the incident
we are thankful in this event that
nobody was hurt
and that the officers did not have to
use deadly force
to bring this incident to safe
resolution the charges that the suspect
is looking at at this point
are assault with a deadly weapon
resisting
with a deadly weapon carrying a
concealed weapon stolen vehicle
and ultimately kidnapping a few counts
and attempt murder on a police officer
this investigation is ongoing and these
are the details as we have them at this
point
thank you yes sir does it
seem like this was a very long like you
mentioned a very methodical
uh process it seemed like the momentum
of the scene had been slow considerably
is that part of a concerted effort that
maybe
so listen this is what these guys train
for there is a time
where they need to use force and move
quickly but they also recognize that
this was one of those times that time
we could slow down communicate the
subject was willing to communicate with
us
and we used all of the negotiation
tactics available to us
to bring this to a peaceful resolution
and it is all about the sanctity of life
and de-escalation yes ma'am
um they will release it once the booking
process is completed
yes does the suspect know the baby sir
not that we are aware of
any word on the fact that when our
officers see someone concealing a weapon
like that this could have very quickly
turned into an ois
and he instead chose to de-escalate the
situation anywhere
typical tactic yes ma'am as you know we
are constantly
training with our officers all of the
different techniques available to them
to de-escalate a situation
sometimes that is creating distance and
in this case creating distance was
absolutely the right thing for him to do
so
so this started around 10 30 it might
have been around
and i'm guessing
uh six o'clock four five o'clock six
o'clock last night
was the suspect wanted for anything
before this or do you know what the
charges
you know what that part of the
investigation is still ongoing i'm sure
that we'll have to do a later press
brief thank you guys for your time we
appreciate it